bienvenidos de nuevo en este vídeo
seguiremos trabajando con área bajo la
curva sin embargo lo que quiero
aclararles es que los vídeos anteriores
construimos toda la noción fundamental
para entender qué es el área debajo de
la curva y por qué el área bajo de la
curva es la andi derivada pero bueno
antes de seguir con estos ejercicios yo
quiero llamar al teorema fundamental del
cálculo anotarlo aquí y entenderlo muy
bien nos va a ser muy útil en todos los
ejercicios posteriores que vamos a hacer
el teorema fundamental del cálculo dice
que si f mayúscula la derivamos con
respecto a x nos da una f minúscula de x
si una función la derivamos nos da otra
función que por cierto esto es lo mismo
que si pasamos la derivada del otro lado
pero la derivada del otro lado va a
pasar como integral esto quiere decir
que la derivada y la integral son
funciones inversas entonces nos quedaría
que f mayúscula de x es igual paso la
derivada del otro lado a la integral de
f minúsculas de x de x estas dos
renglones son lo mismo un renglón te
está diciendo lo mismo que el otro caso
como el primer renglón entonces lo voy a
atrapar y ahora si me va a servir mucho
el primer rector porque dice el teorema
fundamental del cálculo si pasa esto si
pasa lo que estoy encerrando de color
naranja si pasa y entonces podemos
hablar de la integral definida que va a
decir si pasa que f prima de x f
mayúscula prima de x es igual a fx
entonces la integral de a a b de quien
de f minúsculas de x de x es igual a efe
mayúscula al anti derivada oa la
primitiva evaluada en b y a esto le
vamos a quitar f mayúscula es decir la
anti derivada evaluada en a esto lo que
me dice el programa fundamental del
cálculo y en esto voy a basar todo lo
que voy a ver posteriormente de hecho
todos los ejercicios que vamos a ver es
aplicar simple sencillamente esta
fórmula pero antes de irnos esos
ejercicios quiero aclararles una cosa si
nosotros integramos una función que no
es definida siempre aparece una
constante la famosa constante de
integración sin embargo aquí no aparece
y eso es debido a que si la pusiéramos
se cancelaría si ponemos la constante
menos la constante pues no nos queda
nada entonces no es necesario ponerlo
pero ahora si vamos al primer ejercicio
de este vídeo
voy a suponer que este es mi eje de las
leyes este va a ser mi ejes las x miren
que parejos me quedaron esta vez muy
bien y voy a tomar una función a semana
toca tomar una parábola pero una palabra
que no esté en el origen voy a decir que
fx va a ser igual a equis cuadrada para
que es una parábola pero le voy a sumar
un equis cuadrada más uno bien como se
vería la gráfica de esto pues corten el
uno por aquí va a pasar y se abren como
una parábola hacia arriba entonces aquí
está mi gráfica de mi palabra no me
quedó perfecta pero bueno se ve bien no
no está tan mal y ahora yo lo que voy a
querer es sacar el área bajo esta curva
desde un punto por aquí vamos a tomar un
punto cualquiera bueno voy a tomar el
menos uno para no hacerlo tan difícil
a este punto de camps este punto de acá
que va a ser el 3 yo quiero el área bajo
la curva o el área abajo la gráfica de
esta función de 1 a 3 quiero todo esto
de aquí bien esto que estoy coloreando
es lo que quiero obtener y bueno voy a
utilizar el teorema fundamental del
cálculo entonces pues es hora de
aplicarlo si yo quiero el área bajo la
curva necesito la anti derivada evaluada
en los límites de integración es decir
entre 3 y menos 1 sin embargo quiero que
se den cuenta una cosa si no tuviéramos
la herramienta tan importante del
cálculo es sacar el área el área bajo la
curva de esta parábola no sería nada
sencillo no estaría nada fácil sin
embargo ahora que ya tenemos el teorema
fundamental del cálculo el obtener esta
área que yo quiero es muy sencillo
simple sencillamente tenemos que hacer
la integral de donde donde de menos 1 a
3 de fx de x osea de x cuadrada más
todo esto multiplicado por equis y esta
integral ya es lo integran muy sencilla
realmente no hay mucho que complicarse
la vida la integral de esto es igual a
equis cúbica entre 3 la integral de x
cuadrado es x cúbica entre 3 le sumamos
un el exponente y lo dividimos recién
número ya esto hay que sumarle el
integral de uno de x que es x ya esto
hay que evaluarlo todo entre mis límites
de integración o sea entre 3 y menos 1
voy a ponerlo aquí entre 3 y menos 1 y
darse cuenta que es mucho más fácil
resolverlo de una manera monótona que
entender todo el concepto de los
rectángulos que se hacían muy pequeños y
la infinidad de rectángulos y las sumas
infinitas es mucho más fácil aplicar
solamente el teorema fundamental del
cálculo otra cosa que quiero que
observemos es que no es necesario poner
la constante integración
la constante integración desaparece
porque se anularía tarde o temprano al
evaluar en el índice superior y en el
índice inferior
ahora bien vamos a evaluar qué pasa en
tres en tres nuestra 12 porque 3 al cubo
es 27 entre
es 93 son 12 esto es la primitiva o la
anti derivada evaluada en 3 no olviden
que el resultado de la integración es la
anti derivada bien ahora voy a evaluar
en menos uno menos uno al cubo es menos
1 entre 3 me quedan menos tres a menos
un tercio más menos uno que me va a
quedar menos un tercio menos uno es lo
mismo que menos cuatro tercios no sé si
tres más unos cuatro si menos cuatro
tercios entonces lo voy a notar a efe la
primitiva o la anti derivada evaluada en
menos uno me queda menos cuatro tercios
y ahora solamente hay que resolver esta
operación muy sencilla
12 - menos cuatro tercios de hecho menos
y menos se vuelve más entonces voy a
poner aquí más más y como es la última
operación que hay que hacer en lugar de
sacar el mínimo común múltiplo simple y
sencillamente nos voy a juntar 12 más
cuatro tercios es dos enteros cuatro
tercios bien y ya acabamos por fin este
resultado el área que hay abajo de la
curva x cuadrada
desde el punto x menos 1 hasta el punto
x igual a 3 es igual a dos enteros
cuatro tercios bien pero hagamos un
nuevo ejemplo acerca del teorema
fundamental del cálculo para esto voy a
dibujar mis ejes coordinados voy a decir
que este es mi eje de las íes y no me
quedo tan mal bien y este es mi eje de
las equis y por lo que estoy viendo el
tiempo espero que me alcance realmente
voy a intentar que me alcance el tiempo
siempre lo intento pero si no me alcanza
lo veremos en el siguiente vídeo bueno y
me voy a tomar ahora la función fx igual
a la raíz de x que si nosotros la
gráfica mos se ve más o menos
bien esta es mi función
fx estas micas las x y por lo tanto
entonces este va a ser mi eje de fx y
ahora supongamos que en el mismo plano
cartesiano en el de los mismos ejes
coordenadas tengo otra función mi
función de x igual a x cuadrado
esta gráfica ya la conocemos muy bien es
esta de aquí la voy a dibujar
bien perfecto y de hecho esta función
continua del otro lado también podremos
dibujar un poco del otro lado es algo
como así no importa tanto lo que no
importa es lo que va a pasar en el
primer cuadrante bueno ahora la pregunta
de este de esta parte del vídeo es cómo
puedo yo encontrar el área que está
entre las dos curvas el área que se
quedó atrapada cuando se interceptaron
las dos curvas esta que estoy coloreando
aquí y bien para resolver esta pregunta
lo que primero que esto saber es en qué
punto se intersectan mis dos funciones
si yo sé en qué puntos intersectan ya
voy a tener los límites de integración
lo primero que vemos y es muy sencillo
de analizar es que se intersectan en el
0 0 ahora podríamos a crear el otro
punto por pura inspección sin embargo si
no supiéramos cuál es el otro punto de
intersección lo que hay que hacer es
igualar las dos funciones porque este
punto está tanto en una función en fx
como en la otra función en que de x es
decir x cuadrado es igual a la raíz de x
y bueno para resolver esta ecuación
podemos resolver las de varias for
y podría llevar todo el cuadrado y de
ahí me quedaría que x cuarta es igualdad
x idea y resolver sin embargo ya no me
voy a complicar más la vida y lo voy a
hacer por pura inspección uno de los
puntos es x igual a 0 y el otro va a ser
x igual a 11 cumple para las dos
ecuaciones y de hecho tengo el punto 1,1
resolver esta cuestión x cuadrado igual
a raíz de x era pura álgebra y como ya
casi no tengo tiempo lo dice por pura
infección ahora bien cómo puedo yo
obtener el área entre las dos curvas si
yo fuera tú pasaría este vídeo y me
preguntaría cómo obtener la solución sin
embargo ya que tengo muy poco tiempo voy
a seguir con este vídeo y la idea va a
ser sacar el área bajo la curva o sea el
área que está abajo de la función de x
igual a x cuadrado toda esta área la voy
a sacar porque es lo que voy a hacer es
restar el área de fx igual a raíz de x
menos el área de eje x igual a x
cuadrada este va a ser mi solución y de
ahí parte la idea pero lo voy a hacer en
el siguiente vídeo